hey you said something about getting
waste there was a period where you were
sober yeah I did for four years four
years and then you like now you just
like just rock
no I have uh in and during covid kind of
did it again because it was like all
right go skate and then barbecue and
then drink sounded like on Shark Week
you got pretty hammered in the airport
oh yeah I did I got hammered in Shark
Week the whole time what did you yeah
but but what's so crazy is and it's so
funny and I don't mean to bring him up
but bam always is like when when we were
talking about jackass four right like
you can't party you can't do nothing
right
we've been allowed to go partying all
that because we man's not showing up in
jails and psych wards and rehabs yeah
and it's like wee man's not like one
time I tried to uh that was just trying
to get through the BAM and I was like I
I just typed into the search bar of TMZ
and Margaret just to like just to kind
of go through it just the feed of his
art and it was like so gnarly just one
thing after another everything it was
just like I was just like bam it was
like Trump typing in Trump on CNN or
something like it just like yeah I don't
want to get like yeah
we don't need to do that yeah but yeah
but
yeah so that bad clearly you you don't
have to go to rehab you're not showing
up in jail yeah I don't wake up oh dude
I need to party you know right right
right right I'll just like if it's a
good time and we're having a good time
when's the last time you've been drunk
last night no uh over the weekend I got
it wasn't my I just get buzzed with you
know because I was out with The Chronic
Taco dudes yeah but I don't go out and
get like crazy like we used to we used
to go out and we'd be like fine chicks
party blah you know and now it's just
like adult style we just have a good
time I think that clip was awesome but
not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what I've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions my
first books Five star rated on Amazon
and I have no doubt this one will be too
so get the autograph copy right now at
stevo.com
yeah dude